every week brings another flurry of
people being censured
fired or pushed to resign for some
purported instance of racism
sexism or wrong think harper's magazine
published a controversial letter
signed by over 150 people including
salman rushdie
jk rowling and noam chomsky warning that
the free exchange of information and
ideas
the lifeblood of a liberal society is
daily becoming more constricted
one of the signatories of the letter was
camille foster he's the co-founder of
free think
a media company that showcases social
and technological innovations
a co-host of the fifth column podcast
and an outspoken libertarian critic
of black lives matter cancel culture and
political orthodoxy
in this wide-ranging interview foster
explains why he signed the letter on
cancel culture
why he thinks that racism is not the
primary factor
for most african-americans success or
failure
and why libertarians need to be pushing
individualism
now more than ever
[Music]
camille foster thanks for talking to the
reason interview
with nicholas thank you have i mentioned
i'm nick gillespie okay
thank you so i wanted to talk with you
for a while about a lot of stuff and
part of this is
um you are you are a black man who does
not identify as black
um and we're going to talk more about
that in a minute but
i was thinking i guess it was late last
year i interviewed thomas chatterton
williams about his fantastic
recent book self-portrait in black and
white and i was
i was happy although not surprised to
see you pop
up in the pages of that book is somebody
um
you know uh chatterton williams is is i
think in a bold move that
both is prescient and kind of ignored in
the current moment where he was talking
about
leaving blackness as a category behind
and embracing
a kind of liberal in the classical sense
and also kind of a contemporary sense of
liberal individualism
and um you know and that the only way to
get rid of uh
you know racial strife in a way is to
deny
it as a building a foundational block of
our society
and and of course you came up in that
conversation where he
you had an impact on him um more
recently
thomas chatterton williams put together
pulled together a bunch of luminaries
like 150 people that included uh
everybody from jk rowling to
a man named camille foster to uh
denounce
um what you know a broadly can you know
uh
construed uh cancel culture uh this
letter appeared in harper's matt welch
has written about it uh
memorably at reason can you talk uh
camille about what what's the point of
the letter
and why did you sign it well first thank
you again nick it's always a pleasure to
chat with you
um the this letter uh came to me
a couple iterations before the one that
actually ended up getting released and
initially
um it was a bit more explicit um in
suggesting that this was you know a
dispatch from people who identify as
liberals i
i actually identify as a libertarian so
it's a bit of a difference
part of your problem that's why you're
talking to me
we're going to talk about libertarianism
uh
zooms in a little bit but please
continue
um but the ultimately
the reason i signed it and my suspicion
is to the reason all of the other
signatories sign it most of whom i do
not know personally
is because i have grown increasingly
concerned
about the climate that exists in the
united states today
um i perhaps have noticed it most
in media i know a lot of people in
newsrooms all over
the place and have heard a lot about
the sensorious attitude and atmosphere
the sense that there are all kinds of
things that
simply cannot be said anymore um
i hesitate to use the word totalitarian
in some instances but i don't really
anymore with this there's a somewhat
totalitarian feeling about the
desire to force people to either conform
to a particular point of view or endorse
it it's not enough
to to simply disagree quietly
well silence silence equals consent
or violence right i mean
yeah okay so uh and you know one of the
people who is a co-signatory
uh was barry weiss of the new york times
and we're recording this on tuesday
july 14th weiss has just who we both
know um has just uh announced her
resignation from the new york times
opinion page saying that you know the
atmosphere there is so toxic and
poisonous
uh that she's she's done um that's what
you're talking about right
um is it's i mean it's not we and and i
think we need to be clear here because
there's
there's an interesting argument uh
counter argument
uh that i'll get to in a second but that
it's not that you can't say what you
want
it's that the minute you say something
that kind of goes against
a a far left really a kind of
narrow consideration of what is
considered uh
an acceptable acceptable viewpoint
you will be attacked on twitter you will
be attacked uh
you know on the pages of the internet
the infinite pages of the internet for
being racist sexist
uh anti-trans all sorts of things
right so it's not it it's not quite
right to say that you can't say these
things
and the people who are pushing for
canceled culture say we're you know
we're
participating in free speech all we're
doing
we are we are voices that have not been
heard before we were locked out in the
bad old days of three tv networks and a
couple of radio you know national radio
stations
and things like that and now we have a
voice and we are coming for you camille
foster barry weiss
uh you know salman rushdie another
signatory
of the uh of the letter uh you know and
jk rowling when you
say things that we think are reactionary
and awful
um why is tell me this then
because you know i i'm on your side and
and matt welch and i have talked a lot
about this
at in in reason context of you know that
it's not enough to simply say
uh you know we believe in free speech
and but we also believe that twitter
youtube uh et cetera they're private
platforms so they have the right to say
you know what get
get off i just saw that rush v or you
know uh the roosh or whatever the
the pickup artist guy was bounced from
youtube and was crying about it on
twitter
i don't have a lot of love for him or
his material but
i do believe that it's it's a bad thing
when platforms start to
narrowly restrict everything we need a
climate of free speech
i guess i'm asking there's a wind-up to
say what is wrong with the argument
advanced by some of your critics
critics of the letter who say you know
cancel culture
is a phantasm it doesn't exist what it's
about
is holding other people accountable for
their
reckless stupid dangerous speech yeah a
little bit of housekeeping here because
i think some background is necessary
i'm i'm someone who's arrived at a place
where i feel
comfortable signing a letter like this
somewhat reluctantly
um and and fairly recently actually uh
i've long thought that there have always
been things that you can't say
uh in polite society and there have
always been consequences
to be visited upon people who say those
things what are those things
i mean what you know that i'm not trying
to ask yeah
no in the past it could be any number of
things in the past
to simply advocate for racial equality
for example was
a dangerous idea to to say that
uh it is no great peril for
people to be involved in interracial
relationships um was not was a dangerous
idea yeah
just as a side point uh this that
floored man i remember
uh going through this when when obama
was first running for president
uh when he was born in the late 50s
early 60s about two percent of americans
according to gallup
approved of interracial uh relationships
it only passed the majority in like the
mid 80s
right you know and now it's in the high
80s 90s and it's
you know it's it's the dominant you know
by far hegemonic that nobody
bats an eye much less says anything
publicly about any kind of interracial
uh you know however you define that
relationship but within our you know
within my lifetime anyway
sure you know this this is a big change
yeah yeah and
and look the fact that there are some
headwinds to be fought by people who are
advocating for important but unpopular
ideas
is not something that i am too concerned
with
um i have however arrived at a place
where i am deeply concerned about
the scope of things that are becoming
dangerous to say
and the degree to which there is an
obvious appetite for
censorship and speech and thought
policing not just
on the left but on the left and the
right there is no consensus in terms of
the kinds of things that each side hates
necessarily
but there is a general attitude and a
sensibility that says
there are some things that are either
too dangerous for you to hear
or too dangerous for anyone to be
allowed to say what is what's
scope and category of things is is
increasing
in a way that makes me very nervous and
i think the
the authoritarian potential that exists
in a climate like that especially in the
midst of a pandemic when
and i don't think this is crazy to
suggest it is very likely
that over the course of the next decade
we'll have
more government not less and it's very
likely i think that's the safest bet you
could make
i mean that's that'll pay off better
than a treasury
bill and greater entitlement spending
and entitlement programs
so we're talking about a government
that's more powerful and an atmosphere
that is already inclined towards
censorship
that is an incredibly dangerous
combination and the right
to speak freely is the most fundamental
right that we have
and when you get sort of official
challenges to that right
you you probably have to have a culture
that's a bit pliable
and to the extent that we're already
seeing things and i
i can tell you nick i get notes from
people and i'd be interested if you do
as well
i get notes from people almost every day
in every walk of life
who are expressing a great deal of
concern and consternation
about the degree to which they see
things changing
they're encountering speech policing and
and really
kind of cultural programming in context
that shocked them
and in a in a way that doesn't allow
them any opportunity to push back
what are some concern about that what
are what are some of the uh
you know instances that exemplify this
on the left and on the right
for you um because again you know it is
it's technically and and meaningfully
true to
say that like you you can say whatever
you want pretty much and if you can't do
it on twitter you go to parlor if you
can't do it on youtube you can create
your own
streaming stuff like that but what you
know what what are you talking about and
also
i i i want to drill down a little bit
you are not making an equivalency
between what's going on say with donald
trump and what's going on on the left
are you no but i don't i guess we have
to drill down and talk about
what specific things the left or donald
trump are doing that aren't equivalent
so
you know when you know when you were
signing the letter and you're like okay
i'm going to sign this
note from people and you are kind of an
outlier because you're a libertarian as
opposed to a kind of mainstream
liberal or or even kind of progressive i
mean somebody like salman rushdie or or
jk rowling for instance and barry weiss
or
you know they are kind of you know
centrist
you know centrist liberals modern
contemporary liberals you're not that
but
what did you have in mind when you were
like i gotta i gotta sign
uh this well first that that diversity
of perspective that you just underscored
was a principle reason for me to sign
the letter i mean noam chomsky is also a
signer
disagree on virtually everything right
but what we agree on
is the importance of a culture that
is generally inclined towards allowing
being permissive
and giving folks an opportunity to make
mistakes and the specter
of there being genuine formal challenges
to speech protections um i know that
folks like donald trump and
conservatives constantly
bang on about the the prospect of their
speech being
censored on facebook or other social
media platforms and the need for laws to
fix
this problem um and in a
different sort of fashion i know that
polling has consistently found that
younger americans
think it is appropriate to uh outlaw
certain kinds of speech because it might
be offensive to minorities
in both instances i think these impulses
are understandable
in the sense that they're discernible
but they're wrong
um and i i think that again to the
extent the culture
the cultural things occur first and they
are
perhaps presaging what may happen in in
our political
um lives then it seems very important
the supreme court reads the newspapers
right and uh you know the supreme court
has been phenomenal over the past 10 or
20 years on free speech issues uh
but uh it's a lagging indicator right so
if the culture gets very
um kind of repressive suppressive
restricted kind of constipated one
assumes that
you know the supreme court and laws will
follow suit
do you believe that conservatives are
systematically
um uh kind of uh that their audiences
are are shriveled up on on platforms
like twitter or youtube facebook
or do you think they're kind of off in
cuckoo land with that
i'd say that places like twitter at
least in the way that i interact with it
and it's important to note that you know
our experiences
on these platforms are very tailored to
us
and i have cultivated a particular kind
of experience and it leans left
without a doubt and the voices on the
left are the most prominent ones
in my twitter ecosystem i do
have a lot of libertarian
friends and followers um and i get a lot
of that
as well but the things that are most
likely to be amplified
are the outrages that are coming from
the left
um so i it's hard to say
um in any sort of formal sense but what
seems important to me
is as you mentioned conservatives have
any number of ways to communicate with
the public
and the president of the united states
certainly doesn't have any trouble
telling the public what he thinks and
leveraging twitter to do just that
um i am far from concerned
uh about any peril posed
by twitter and facebook generally
speaking
um kind of dealing with their platform
as they please
uh in order to to sort of regulate
how uh people use utilize that platform
there have been some things
that make me slightly nervous i think
the instinct to
have twitter and facebook serve as the
the arbiters
of what is true and factual um i think
is a real problem and has all sorts of
uh dangers that people are probably not
aware of i think that the impulse to
outsource
our critical thinking and our evaluation
the requirement that we evaluate
the truth and accuracy of the things
that we encounter is a really bad
instinct
and i know that it's hard to figure out
what's true
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't do
it you're always responsible for that
you can't wait for someone to vlog
box plain things to you most of the
things that are important
are going to take a little bit of effort
on your part they're going to be
non-obvious
so uh speaking of vox uh one of the
other
signatories and i guess this gets to uh
you know
kind of the climate that we're talking
about here which is
short of you know the uh the cop showing
up
at your door and uh forcing you to the
camps or anything like that but
one of the co-signatories of the letter
was matt iglesias of vox
and then a colleague of his uh
who is a uh uh a trans uh
writer wrote um that uh or
tweeted uh a part of a letter that uh
was
that they wrote to um to the vox
bigwigs and matt is one of the iglesias
is one of the co-founders of the
organization i don't know what active
role he has in the management of it
saying that um they did not want
iglesias to be
fired or reprimanded in any way but they
wanted to make the management know
that uh they felt unsafe as a result of
the letter
um is that the kind of like is that a
bad
thing um or is that a way of applying
pressure
which is broadly within the realm of
using free speech
to kind of nudge and push and work the
refs in your direction
for the kind of world and the kind of
discourse you want or
you know and i guess in another way what
what is wrong with that kind of
um i you know i g i could call it
passive aggressive i don't know i mean
but like where
hey i don't i don't want anything bad to
happen to this person but i want the
world to know
that as a result of a guy i work with
signing a letter in a different
publication
i feel less safe at work yeah well
people
people ought to have the ability to go
to their employers
and talk about the fact they feel unsafe
i think what matters here isn't so much
that it happens at all
it's the scope of things for which it
happens and
it's generally a culture and a climate
that suggests that even
trying to evaluate the quality of these
concerns
and the substance of these concerns is
somehow
problematic in and of itself and i think
that that
is ridiculous i think it is obviously
true that the letter that was written
is not at all transphobic one of the
principal complaints that i saw
targeted at the signatories is that
somehow or another
because this diverse group of people
with very different ideas
all sign this document that they are not
only endorsing
the contents of the letter which is
pretty benign frankly and and
uh deliberately so um that they are
somehow endorsing all of one another's
positions
right which is just absurd have on that
rowling of course who is now probably
more famous for being a turf a trans
uh uh a trans exclusionary radical
feminist uh
according to sam yes yeah then the harry
potter books but also george mccloskey a
long-term long-time contributing editor
to uh
reason magazine who has been a
contributing editor from the time she
was
donald mccloskey and who in other
contexts
is is held up as somebody who attacks
people
who question the um the the kind of
naturalness of
of being trans so it's yeah i mean we
get into
deep kind of waters pretty quickly
do you think you know i mean would you
say that like the idea that that letter
would make anybody feel unsafe
is i mean you you have trouble
understanding
the the the kind of legitimacy not not
the fact of that concern but like
what's going on in the same way that um
black
uh staffers at the new york times said
publishing
tom cotton's op-ed about right you know
bringing the troops in to police the
cities for riots that have not really
taken place
or civil unrest that is abated um you
know a bunch of new you know new york
times
uh staffers said that black new york
times writers are
endangered by the publication of that i
mean are you
right saying like these are not nutso
concerns and we should be
we should be pushing back against that
type of
hyper uh exaggerated fear
i i generally yeah i think it's
appropriate to be
critical of those concerns to ask people
to substantiate their complaints
there's nothing uh un
inappropriate about that in fact i think
it is the ultimate sign of respect
to say that i will treat you as i would
anyone else
and i respect your right to bring these
allegations
i would only ask that you substantiate
them what do you mean
makes them unsafe in what way does it
make them unsafe
in what way does this letter make you
feel unsafe ultimately
employers present people in positions of
authority have to make determinations
about whether or not they'll respond to
some claims
otherwise you get into this arms race of
competing concerns and in a universe
where
we're discovering an infinite number
of protected classes of citizens we seem
to manufacture these things quite
quickly now
the the universe of things that you will
not be able to say
because protected person x has made a
claim
against you which you're unable to
challenge um
is just going to create a world that is
not only
not only boring and uninteresting but
actually kind of savage and dangerous
yeah but can i
from a libertarian perspective uh you
know and this is something i
i i you know somewhat disagree with some
of my
colleagues that reason i don't want to
overstate that or misstate it but
isn't that kind of a libertarian world
where we have
endlessly competing private firms and
platforms and
voluntary organizations which might be
workplaces or commun online communities
where you're constantly writing your own
line you know you're writing your own
rules and if you don't like it well [ __ ]
it
go you know go out on the prairie and
start your own
you know i mean but is i mean is that
actually libertarian to
to kind of like turn every work every
workplace every meeting place into this
horrifying struggle session where it's
it's constant purification
and if that is consistent with
libertarian ideology
are are we doing something wrong because
you said yeah that it's a boring
uh you know boring and terrifying world
if you can never
speak because you're gonna [ __ ] piss
somebody off somewhere
right interestingly i don't think i
arrive here
because of my libertarian beliefs uh the
the fundamental
libertarian value is this belief and a
right to speech
but it is libertarianism isn't
necessarily a philosophy from which you
can derive
all of your other values and it seems to
me
that a culture that is generally
permissive
is one in which rights to free speech
are best protected
so that is why i place a particular
value on that and think other people
ought to as well
so i advocate for it you know in much
the same way i think you own your dog
and if you want to feed him you know
[ __ ] dog food that is up to you
libertarianism doesn't suggest are you
working against product
placement taking care of him are you
gonna work in a product placement now of
like you know
how old are you camille if i'm not uh
i'm 39.
now 30 i would have got you are older
than i expected but you missed yeah
i'm i'm in extraordinary shape you are
you are you know what i want to
say perhaps not as useful as you but i
too am youthful
or so called i don't get the letters of
people saying i am being hounded out of
work
for slightly being off of center i get
uh you know like you're doing you're
looking pretty good considering you're
ancient i'm almost 20 years old which is
a nightmare to think about
uh but i was going to say there was a
period in um
in sitcom i guess the tv history where
for whatever reason the networks
wouldn't show
actual brands and so like on all in the
family archie bunker would drink cans of
uh yellow can that said beer on it
rather than like a budweiser or anything
i don't know what happened if it was
yeah fcc change or the networks realize
they could do product placement or
something but
um so if you do want to do product
placement this is a privately owned and
operated platform
uh understood podcast so you can go
ahead and we'll talk about
free think media anyway which yeah so
you'll you'll get to promote uh you'll
get to do a little bit of business later
a lot of the um you know the a lot of
the arguments over free speech and what
constitutes cancer culture free speech
uh you know censorship um revolve around
racial grievances uh you know and this
is particularly true
um in the wake of the pandemic and the
george floyd killing
um and then black lives matter protests
and whatnot
um you know first off what
can i ask you you you have a kind of
idiosyncratic
and i think complicated and interesting
i'm not sure i
buy into it completely a kind of
description
of race or of the fictitiousness
of race can you do a summary of where
you're coming from
uh when you think about categories of
blackness and whiteness
i can try and i'd be interested in
knowing where you where you depart from
me
to begin biologically and genetically
race is not a thing
there are populations geneticists often
talk about that
and there are subpopulations etc cetera
but the notion of there being
races in the conventional sense the the
way that we generally talk about them
blackness and whiteness of
me being half black and half white for
example or asian whatever the hell that
means
um yeah an asian by the way is the
weirdest
or not the weirdest thing but i mean
just to underscore the
the kind of social construction of these
identities you know
it used to mean something in an american
context now
you know which mostly meant people from
china are from east asia and now it
includes south asians so pakistanis and
uh and indians are asian as well and
it's kind of like
that's kind of a head scratcher if you
went back to the you know the korean war
period or something but
and the notion of blackness isn't much
better i mean the the
abundance of genetic and cultural
diversity that is subsumed
under the label of black in in a way we
and we toss it around as if it's
informative
um is is mind-boggling so i begin there
and i begin with an understanding that
blackness and whiteness
are things that are born out of a
historical context and these are
ideas that were designed to separate
and categorize human populations largely
for the purpose of subjugation
um and and this is where you know
chinese and indians
face the same kind of governmental rules
essentially it was
until relatively recently uh you know
after world war ii was technically
illegal for these groups
to really become citizens as as
immigrants to america and legally gain
citizenship
so yeah so you know as as a person
comfortably sitting so to speak from the
vantage point of 2020 it was a little
more comfortable in 2019 if i if i
admit it um but comfortably sitting from
the vantage point of 2020
um i can say candidly that i've been
able to live a privileged life
in which my race has not been an
obstacle
in a professional or official sense
with respect to the laws of this land
that i don't think
i have any sort of obligation to
identify
on the basis of what many might presume
about me with respect to my
identity on account of my immutable
characteristics
and i don't think that it's terribly
valuable for most people
um for me to actually regard them in
that way because we are at bottom all
individuals
so race being phony baloney science
race having this all of this political
and cultural baggage
and in a contemporary context being
largely a matter of
like individual choice the question
comes to me camille
what what are you what do you choose to
be
how do you self-identify i see no reason
whatsoever to self-identify on the basis
of race and
a great many shortcomings and drawbacks
associated with reifying
and propagating the notion of racial
identity
and racial difference as a profound
signifier
of great importance about the substance
or quality or nature
of any individual person who are your
heroes though in coming to that
and do you i mean are you saying um
you know the the cartoon version of that
would be that you have a
and listening to you i'm hearing echoes
of earlier
uh thoughts by african-american writers
and sas
not just thomas chatterton williams
who's your contemporary but
people like richard wright and to a
certain degree james baldwin
richard wright uh you know famously
moved to france uh the author of native
son
uh because he felt freer uh in a foreign
country
and was an existentialist to a certain
degree but also i mean
who who are your heroes because you're
making a kind of radical act
of of self-expression and you're kind of
saying no
no to race um in a way that race may not
be saying no to you
but so first first question who are who
are the people who helped you get to you
know your articulation of of kind of
this
um you know breathtaking really uh
individual choice of of self-composition
well i'd say that james baldwin is
certainly one of those people
and james can be read in a number of
different ways which is why both
um tnc um and myself uh
both sort of hold him up as someone who
is incredibly influential and important
thank you being tana hey coats correct
you you you
don't agree with on very many things
would you
that's correct yeah yeah i would say
that um and zora neale hurston
is another person who's a real
iconoclast and has had some
very important things to say about race
and race pride
and the degree to which these are
limited
ideas um that are probably harmful to us
would you say with somebody likes or
neil hurston though
uh you know who's best known now mostly
rescued by alice walker
in many ways another a black writer who
you share very little with i would
suspect
other than a belief in lizard illuminati
um fake news
yeah zora neale hurston um
she was certainly her her life was
circumscribed by race don't you think in
in many prophets yeah she also referred
to herself as a as a member of the
nicaragua if i'm not mistaken right um i
i i concur
that i've sort of taken parts of
ideas from different people and
not because i am so remarkable but i've
kind of cobbled together my own
philosophy around this and i've been
delighted to discover that other people
have
come to similar conclusions really
brilliant people like barbara fields
at columbia university who wrote a
brilliant book called racecraft which
definitely uh comes at this from a
different political perspective
um but reaches many of the same
conclusions about the perils
of race and the degree to which we
manufacture and reinforce
notions of race um every single day
um and you know i think that the general
thing if one only takes one thing away
from this
is that what people need to bear in mind
is the degree to which race
divides us and obscures the truth and
the the last part of the trifecta is
generally ruins everything
like there are lots of important
conversations that get hopelessly bogged
down
in all of the political and cultural
awfulness that accompanies a
conversation about race
and that awfulness unfortunately isn't
isn't going away in the present moment
yeah can i ask though you know and this
is kind of a factor and i'm gonna
i'm gonna mess up his quote but you know
how faulkner
in one of his later works actually i
think it's a requiem for a nun
comes the famous line in the south you
know the past uh
the past isn't dead it's not even past
is that true about race i mean because
and i guess you know we were talking
about the racial grievances that are
really
um kind of energizing a lot of the
conversations
about cancer culture and whatnot um and
you know black lives matter is is
is a kind of ascendant broad-based
movement
um partly because of the the police
killing of george floyd but
um you know can we just how i guess
what i'm asking is how do we pay um
like homage um and pay the debt of a
racially horrifying society in history
without necessarily perpetuating it
going forward
in the name of expiating the the crimes
of the past
um does that make sense or i i can
rephrase that of like
you know how how do we how do we take
account of the way that racism
you know institutional racism deja rae
and de facto racism
are absolutely part of american society
without then
simultaneously maintaining that
in the name of of getting past it
yeah well i think there's there's
something i've said uh which
maybe i'll get in trouble for saying
again here but you know racism isn't
special
racism isn't racism isn't special um
the the fact of the matter is to the
extent racism has been
a force for evil um in our society
it is often been weaponized by
the state and by concentrations of power
and the fact of the matter is that both
in the united states and around the
world
power has been used to disempower
and take advantage of and dispossess
various minority populations forever and
ever and ever
and there is an infinite
laundry list of historical injuries that
one could
try to adjudicate and i'm not saying
that that's necessarily a bad project
but i do think that there is another
project that ought to be considered
and it's it's really sort of the the mlk
project this this notion of
um uh of pursuing a situation in which
we
actually fulfill the promise of
guaranteeing equal protection under the
law
where we're primarily concerned with
that as our most essential value
and we're not necessarily primarily
concerned
about you know overturning the
meritocratic ideal
that we're seeking um and in
in favor of trying to redress all past
grievances
um so you know i think that there's
something important about recognizing
the degree to which
the contemporary um
uh disparities that we live with that
we're surrounded with and that we face
on a regular basis like have their
historical
component it's perhaps more important
from my standpoint
to recognize that when we actually want
to address
and remedy these problems the the
answers
are generally not race specific and
the answers will likely not require us
to do much
in the way of um sort of bringing
in race or ext protracted conversations
about
you know several hundred years of
oppression if the real problem just to
take one example
is public schools that are failing
many many american children of all
backgrounds even if it's predominantly
failing
young black students then the solution
is what exactly
can we unblock them can we actually wave
a wand and
redress all of these historical injuries
we can't but we can
hopefully create a more innovative and
dynamic school system
that better serves and meets their needs
and
i think those conversations actually
just become fraught and a lot more
difficult
when the only thing that we can talk
about is systemic racism
and the this generally sort of
convoluted
conversation around like white supremacy
and
um you know again historical grievances
i just don't
think it's terribly productive i think
it generally fires people up
it gets the emotions and the passions
flowing
but it isn't obvious to me that it is a
pathway to actually fixing these
problems and i do think that it
threatens that other project of
you know equal protection under the law
which i think is not
just a good goal it's not just a
sufficient goal it is a remarkable
achievement that most people throughout
most of history have not had the
privilege of enjoying
do you think george floyd uh you know
and already he is kind of fading as
a uh you know as the the focus
of of of of energizing outrage and
things like that
did george floyd um have equal
protection under the law or
or do black men in general uh you know
we and we can talk about
you know that the crime rate among black
men is
is elevated in certain ways um but then
in others for
instance in things like um you know
blacks and whites essentially use
marijuana
um in in relatively similar numbers but
if you're black you're much more likely
to uh be arrested
and go to go to prison for using or
possessing marijuana
um so are we you know are we in a place
where we have achieved equality
under the law or are we 90 there
um and you know when you when you see a
case like george floyd
you know it's for the since people
started counting these numbers of police
deaths
um you know going back to around 2014
2013 we
see about a thousand killings by police
a year
blacks are overrepresented but the
majority are
whites who are killed by police but you
know are we
are we seeing a is there a radically
different law enforcement system for
blacks versus whites
that we need to attend to in the same
way that
school outcomes are are so different
yeah so to take that example
specifically i mean they're definitely
disparate impacts uh and it can be said
that in some contexts
it is obviously true that black people
and members of some other minority
communities have worse outcomes than say
their white counterparts
um but it's also true that this is
complicated
and it's complicated by a lot of
different factors people live in
different places we're actually talking
about specific
age groups of black people and specific
genders
of black people and even um specific
communities of black people when you
actually parse
um say native born versus caribbean
black populations in different parts of
brooklyn
you get different economic outcomes and
different crime rates
and different arrest data so these
things become very very
complicated once you take the top off
and it does seem to me that with
policing
police reform in police involved
shootings or injuries
the key question here is are about our
key questions here are about
transparency and accountability and
policy
and a lot of the conversation around
well is it racism call it racism
i think that's that's fine if that's the
sort of thing that you're into
for me i arrive at it's complicated
and more to the point like what can we
actually do to fix this to the extent
we're fixing it we're actually fixing it
for everyone and i will say about george
floyd
briefly and this makes some people
uncomfortable and i think it's all the
more reason to say it
george floyd's death is an awful and
seemingly
completely avoidable and unnecessary
tragedy um i say that seemingly because
this hasn't been adjudicated in the
court of the
law yet and it's not enough to watch a
video and
you know make an appraisal what we want
is a justice system that operates
um for police the same way it operates
for us like you'll get into court
we'll have this out and we will address
the facts and you'll be punished
accordingly
um but it should be said that people
have died
in similar circumstances who are not in
fact black
and it's not obvious to me that we know
with certainty that if george floyd were
something other than black
that he might not have died in an
identical fashion and that seems
to me incredibly important uh
and worth keeping in mind the assumption
and assertion
that race and racism are the fact
motivating factor in these situations
i think can obscure the degree to which
this is a real
police-involved shooting and police
abuses of powers
are generally real problems that all
americans ought to take very seriously
and it also um i think blunts
some of the more hysterical um concern
that's been expressed in certain sectors
by people like benjamin crump
who's this attorney who always shows up
at these events and who's written books
recently about
the campaign of genocide against black
americans
it's it's absurd it's hysterical it
isn't fact-based
and i don't see how it does anything but
animate concern
um without giving us a real uh sort of
mooring in facts and reality and i think
that that matters
um the your
your um uh kind of antagonism towards
black lives matters
can you talk about that because and and
there are two
there are two broad kind of things that
we might call black lives matters right
there's a
an official group or a semi-official
group and then there is a larger
um kind of cultural current that says
uh that blacks have gotten a raw deal
and that until their lives are equal
to you know treated equally as whites um
you know there's a problem but where
where do i mean do either of those
categories of black lives matter
um reach you or are they equally
off base for reasons that you've
discussed
yeah well i mean i think for for reasons
that we've already gotten into you know
i've got manifold concerns
about something like black lives matter
i think
injecting race into certain
conversations where it isn't necessarily
illuminating
is a problem i think exaggerated
over concern about a particular imagined
problem
uh is something that we ought to be
concerned about
um and i think generally you know as a
political movement
uh what black lives matter represents as
a libertarian like there are
certain ideals there and values that are
antithetical to my own
increasing yeah yeah let's talk about
that because uh one of the reasons i
wanted to talk to you now was
uh joe jurgensen who is the libertarian
party
presidential nominee uh tweeted recently
uh saying you know it's not enough to be
kind of color blind like we need to be
we must be anti-racist in our thinking
and you responded
critically to that what was wrong with
her with her
sentiments that that you bristled out so
much
well she she both made that remark about
the requirement the obligation that we
must be anti-racist
um and then she finished that tweet with
hashtag black lives matter um
and it's important to note that in 2020
the the mantra of black lives matter
exists in a political context and is
rated with connotations
and much the same thing can be said
about the notion of anti-racism
um when you ask someone what anti-racism
is they may not really know what you're
talking about i imagine the average
person thinks so that's a that's a
pleasant idea of course i'm anti-racist
i don't like racism
but it matters if you are
aware of the program and for someone
like ibrahim kendi
um who wrote how to be an anti-racist or
uh white fragility which was written by
uh
the the the notion in these books
there's
all kinds of fundamental things that one
must accept
to believe in and to abide by the
principles of anti-racism
you must believe that all racial
disparities
are a function of uh racism
and that the notion of racism must be
broadened from
you know the things that someone does
that are in fact
um sort of uh manifesting uh
their belief that certain races are
inferior to others
um to this nebulous
cloud of action and inaction
and thought and um subconscious
thought uh your mere existence your
actual essence as a person is your
weakness or your blackness
and your guilt um or your
um sort of condition as a perpetual
victim are a function of your race
and these are sort of inescapable uh
inexorable qualities
of who we are and i think that's a
that's a lot of
if i can be frank [ __ ] yeah and it's
possible that joe was unaware of that
context and i do know that she she had a
subsequent
tweet hours later after a number of
people got antimate animated
about this but you know while black
lives matter seems
like uh you know a fairly benign
statement
and perhaps in the minds of many people
just a very objectively good thing i
care about racial injustice and i want
to do something like it so i'm going to
put this black lives matter sign in my
window
um but there is more to the program than
that and to the extent
it it and anti-racism are part of a
broader program that is hostile towards
free markets and capitalism
that is hostile towards notions of
individualism
and the scientific method then these are
things we need to be on guard against
and it is entirely possible for
libertarians to build coalitions with
people they disagree with
to focus on specific policy goals and
hopefully to attract people who care
about those things especially in an
environment where democrats are only
paying lip service
to these issues like qualified immunity
which if you read reason you know
that joe biden has said he does not plan
to do anything
about qualified immunity right i want to
i want joe to appeal
to people who care about black lives
matter on that basis i do not however
want
joe to uh confuse or conflate
libertarian values with what is you know
a hodgepodge
of philosophical bad ideas
by commingling
the libertarian brand with black lives
matter
so what you know you are
you are a rare bird for any number of
reasons one of which is that you are a
libertarian of
african-american descent um
you know one of the critiques so are you
for i mean in a
very real sense yeah yeah no you know
what but not sociologically and i and i
can point you to
the update at 23andme i had about one
percent
unexplained of african north africa
that's a whole another conversation
what they think yeah what you think
they're telling you trust me you know
when you when you were talking about
looking at subpopulations in brooklyn of
of blacks you know uh you know who are
either caribbean descent or not
uh my mother's family is italian and the
italians do worse than i
you are caribbean descent right you're
west indians yeah jamaica first
generation
first generation so and this is this is
actually you know the the
original beef when dan hayes your your
colleague and co-founder of pre-think
media who was working at reason
tv at the time he was like employee
number three of reason tv yeah
he he had met you and he said yeah i met
this fascinating guy who
is black but he doesn't identify as
black he says he's an individual so i
was like wait let me guess he's
from he's a west indian or he's caring
because i've i had encountered that
multiple times and it's kind of an
interesting exceptionalism
but it is true that west indians uh as
a as a sub group of people of americans
do
phenomenally well in new york in a way
that
um you know if we talk about latinos or
hispanics without breaking it down into
cubans and puerto ricans and mexicans
and dominicans
or if we talk about whites and we don't
talk about italian americans who
to this day at least in the new york
area have persistently
lower educational outcomes uh than
other other ethnic groups uh yeah i mean
this is what you're getting at right
like the parsing can go on forever
right like you can you can literally
follow it all the way down right and you
should
because the unit that ultimately matters
is the individual
you're singing my uh tune of uh
friedrich hayek who
you know has his own problems but
believed in methodological individualism
and
you know that in the end when you're
talking about social analysis it's the
individual is the
fundamental unit of analysis not the
group because those are
transitory um but um so
what what i was getting at though is
that you are a you know you're a black
libertarian whether you want you're
perceived that way whether or not you
identify it
why has the libertarian movement which
you know when i think about it and i
came to this
um you know basically through reading
reason as a high schooler
and a college student and then as a grad
student and finally you know
i finally got with the program when they
hired me and started giving me a
paycheck
many years ago but um
you know it's it seems to me that like
the libertarian program of individualism
of capitalism of getting rid of
regulations like occupational licensing
getting rid of dej excuse me desiree
segregation things like school choice
ending the drug war
uh these are the things that should
appeal massively
to minority populations however you want
to define it but the fact of the matter
is is there aren't many black
libertarians
um why do you think that is because part
of you know part of what jorgensen
and i think people who are she was
quoting jonathan blanks who was
who had worked in cato who's
african-american who had been a reason
turn and people like radley balco also
uh now to washington post former reason
staffer who say you know liberty the
libertarian movement is
pretty lilly white and uh you know
that's a
problem right you know
why why aren't there more why aren't
there more black libertarians i guess
that's what i'm asking
well first and foremost um you know i
think an evaluation
of a group that begins with you know an
assessment of whether or not
the the phenotypic traits of that group
are sufficiently representative
and then makes a determination that you
know oh there might be a problem here
um or there is definitely a problem here
i don't i don't really truck with that
um the
the reality is that libertarians have uh
generally speaking
fairly low purchase across the populace
and that black voters tend to not vote
for libertarians but they also tend to
not vote for republicans
um they tend to vote for democrats and
they've done so pretty consistently for
years
the the uniformity there and the
rigidness of that support
um is is an important thing to take into
consideration and i don't know that it
says
much about the specific challenges
associated with libertarianism
um i will say that i do think that
there's a you know an attempt to take a
bit of a shortcut
to try and get to and achieve um sort of
a massive support
amongst black voters by you know hopping
on the bandwagon
uh when it comes to these particular
concerns about systemic racism
and things like black lives matter um
and
one i don't think the project will work
is the is the important thing and look
we're trying the experiment now
um i don't think it will work i think
that you can appeal to people on the
basis of individualism
um and it certainly worked for me and i
think that there is a certain amount of
respect
and dignity that you are awarding to the
people you're trying to persuade
when you don't presume that the only way
to get through to them
is by adopting you know these these
mantras
that also happen to include all of this
racial essentialist
claptrap do you think any of it i mean
because we're really talking about socio
we're certainly not talking about
biology
we're talking more about sociology and
historiography maybe
um and um you know uh
one of the main figures in a kind of
political libertarianism and and most of
the stuff i think we would agree we're
talking about small
libertarians we're not really i mean the
libertarian party is part of that but
it's a
it's a subgroup of it but it's barry
goldwater you know barry goldwater um
you know he laid down with actual
segregationists in 1964 he had voted for
every civil rights law up until he was
running for president
and he voted against the civil rights
act and he didn't just do that
and most people who know him as
biographer left-wing progressive rick
pearlstein will say you know he was not
a racist personally
and in fact in his public policies uh
did a lot to integrate
uh public schools in uh in arizona when
he could and the air national guard
of arizona and things like that but he
hung out with
actual segregationists he gave them you
know aid and comfort
um isn't that part of the reason and a
lot of libertarians you'll talk about oh
barry goldwater is my idea of a great
presidential candidate and he's a guy
who was [ __ ] hanging out with
segregationists um isn't that part of
the reason why libertarians
don't really i mean you know they're i
mean
is that it is is it like so it's just an
accident that you know within historical
memory
uh and then you have people like uh you
know uh
other groups that are still around in
the libertarian movement who talk about
the confederacy
as something other than one of the most
god-awful
incarnations of human depravity um
i i think that that's that's an
interesting proposition
and i've certainly heard that argument
leveled um definitely saw
blanks and um probably radley as well
uh making some pretty loud protestations
that it seems very telling
that libertarians are upset about black
lives matter
being endorsed by the their presidential
nominee well i don't think it's terribly
telling
except for what i just outlined which
has nothing to do with race
and i would i would posit that most
americans
and most black americans included have
no idea who barry goldwater is
i wish it were otherwise but it is so
and the general notion that people
perceive libertarians perceive of
libertarians as
broadly supporting the confederacy or
endorsing
white nationalist sentiment it's a smear
that i encounter frequently
um but i would certainly suggest that
most americans don't have any experience
with either of those strains
of you know retrograde libertarian
uh heresy um i think
that to the extent they've experienced
any libertarianism in their lifetime
it's in hearing you know someone like um
ron paul and not in reading those dodgy
letters
right but experiencing him on the on the
presidential debates
stage and hearing him give um both you
know a credible
articulation of what the ideas were in
that context
and specifically condemning things like
racism and i think libertarians have
a very compelling program both in terms
of its potential benefit to society at
large
and its respect for the individual and
people um
and it's its interest in dismantling
regulatory regimes that make it hard for
small businesses to operate which is
something that lots of black people have
and i think it's fair to appeal to
people
on those terms and to have an
expectation that you can make progress
identity politics is is a thing
and libertarians can if they are so
inclined to try
to play that game um but it's a
compromise that i'm not willing to make
right like joe joe has long odds
of making it as president of the united
states
oh you're breaking my heart
however the party will be around for a
while
and our ideas will endure and
the degree to which we're interested in
diluting them
and corrupting them um or hitching them
to you know some new fad like i think
that matters
and i'm i'm concerned about that and i'm
not
you know i don't want to be a puritan
for the sake of puritanism and ride this
horse into the ground
but i also think that the ideas are
sufficiently important
that someone ought to be defending them
vigorously
at the margins if need be and i think
that's what the libertarian party does
and look we've made progress
on important issues that are core to
libertarians and i know that because
you've helped me to understand that
through your own work nick um
we we own a lot of social issues right
before the
liberals got there first for sure yeah
for sure you know and it's um
and you know it's it's i you know of
course ronald reagan could say you know
there's no
limit to what we can do if you know we
don't care who takes credit because he
got all the credit
it's like you know and i've always when
people say there's no i
in teamwork but there is me you know so
it's like i don't know but libertarians
it's
it's somewhat frustrating particularly
in terms of things like criminal justice
reform and police reform
we've been here yeah been talking about
these things yeah and also you know
welfare if i could just go off on one of
my hobby horses
you know welfare reform i can remember
uh
driving my liberal friends insane when i
would say you know what the
state i i don't i don't know if you
might be more hardcore than me i don't
mind the state giving
uh you know making transfer payments to
people who need help
and but i said to my liberal friends
like get rid of stuff like
section 8 vouchers and health care
medicaid and food stamps and just give
poor people
unrestricted cash grants to spend as
they see fit
and they would be like you're insane
you're insane like how could you
do that and now we have people talking
about a guaranteed minimum income or a
ubi
and whatnot um so yeah libertarians
obviously are always
and everywhere we're clean smelling
we're beautiful we're wonderful and
we're
so far ahead of the curve that we get
left behind and we end up arguing
against things that we were
in favor of when nobody was in favor of
them having said all of that let me
bring it back
the phrase you're looking for is clean
and articulate
that all the time yeah as uh as as
paul's grandfather
in a hard day's night as well he's an
old man who's very clean
uh the um why do
why do blacks vote so overwhelmingly and
for the democratic party then
or is that a meaningful vote to be
talking about and
if i'm doing my uh history right here
and i'm probably
misremembering some things but
eisenhower and nixon both in the
50s up through the 60 election i think
nixon pulled like 35 percent of the
black vote or maybe even a little bit
more
reagan cracked uh in 84
crack double digits since then i mean
trump actually has done better
than uh than mitt romney or john mccain
did
um and i think george bush as well but
uh you know
over the past 50 years uh you know and
certainly since the goldwater years
where jackie robinson you know voted for
nixon he campaigned for nixon in 1960
campaigned against him in 68. you know
why do democrats vote for
why do blacks vote for democrats so
consistently we're in the 90
you know 90 plus range and does that
matter
um in the way that you think about
politics or power in society
um i don't know how much it matters uh
in terms of the way i think about you
know politics and power
um i think one it's it's safe to assume
that they generally agree with them on
on many things
um i think too it's hard for me to deny
what i observe and that is that
amongst the various racial groups
that we have in america uh no group
seems to be more determined
uh in its effort to kind of police um
in-group uh behavior and norms
than blacks for me personally
i get a lot of you know uncle tom and
house [ __ ] and all sorts of other
nasty names because i depart from
orthodoxy
you're not even in the house right
you're not you're not wearing a
bow tie i don't want to be i don't want
to play for the team yeah
you're not wearing a bow tie and
campaigning for trump or anything or a
republican no
none of that yeah yeah but certainly to
do that
you know will get you all sorts of of
nasty behavior so you know the fact that
there's a lot of conformity there
perhaps a little a little unsurprising
for me
uh and i think about folks like michael
steele um who was the lieutenant
governor of maryland before he became an
msnbc contributor and i believe rnc
chairman at one point in the past
um there's an account of him visiting
like morgan state university and being
pelted with oreos it's possible that
that's somewhat apocryphal
but it isn't hard for me to believe that
they were somehow
they were hydrox cookies actually
completely different yeah
um so um yeah and we see that in um
uh chance the rapper a couple of years
ago when kanye west
was flirting with trumpism and said you
know that black should not black should
not necessarily vote for democrats and
chance the rapper a protege of uh kanye
talked about his experiences on twitter
which is where real life happens now
it's kind of strange that we have you
know this empty planet but we're
we're all crowding into twitter but he
said you know his experience
of growing up in chicago was that the
cops were terrible and the schools were
awful and the city fought nobody cared
about his neighborhoods
uh and that he you know that kanye was
right that you know you shouldn't vote
uh democratic he ended up recanting
those sentiments
um that's what you're talking about
although he's recently
as recently as yesterday in fact uh
endorsed
this congress they sent kanye west's
campaign would you vote
would you vote for uh would you vote for
president kanye
i i'll say this it's a possibility
um but i do want to talk to you kim and
kanye
about this run for president i think i
can be helpful
um and to to the extent we can have a
conversation
i not only would they win my support i'm
i'm confident i could help you
garner your addition i don't even think
you could deliver your full
uh family vote i don't know i mean i'd
be curious i could it depends on how
you're talking about my family my wife
like my wife is going to vote for a
ticket that includes me
um or even a white house in which i'm
likely to serve as chief of staff
i mean i think that's my minimal
requirement which i think is fairly
modest
and responsible so when we talk about uh
presidential race because
you you have also uh on the fifth column
the podcast
uh what is that like weekly and you have
a patreon account where you're pulling
in buku bucks now so you have sometimes
a special
not enough never in those yeah no okay
well now you're sounding like your hero
donald trump but like you
you flirt with or i mean would you say
that you or
did you vote for donald trump or would
you vote for donald trump do you think
donald trump
gaining a second term would that be
preferable to joe biden
getting his likely only term i mean uh
joe biden has
william henry harrison written all over
him he's going to catch cold
you know at his inauguration or
something and died 90 days later this
he is he's a frail man but trump versus
biden
what do you see as preferable from a uh
a specifically libertarian view
yeah well you asked a particular
question did i vote for donald trump and
the answer to that question is no
um would i vote for donald trump um i'll
i'll answer in this way
um i generally don't vote and
to the extent i was to vote for someone
there would have to be a pretty damn
good reason
and it's hard to imagine that donald
trump would be able to muster
the sort of miracle that would be
required for me to go out
what would he what would be what would
he have to do would he have to
again chief of staff i'd probably have
to be
i'd probably have to be involved in a
way that i couldn't be fired
in a way that i couldn't be quickly
fired okay um
because because i'd at least have an
opportunity to change things but yeah
that's probably a no but i will say
you know in terms of the evaluating the
benefits
of a trump presidency versus the biden
presidency
and even my somewhat notorious
reputation for being someone who's
willing to
articulate the perspective that donald
trump is
miserable and awful but he's not all of
the worst things that you imagine
and in many respects he like actually
possesses qualities that make him
about as bad as some of our other recent
presidents
um would you people think that's a
defense trump versus obama
much of a defense i mean would would you
say i mean
would you grant that all of the 21st
century presidents have been awful so
far
uh generally in important respects yeah
yeah
okay yeah so um what what is it about
trump that you
think he's not so awful and what is it
about biden
that word issue well it when i say not
so awful it's more so
not as bad as you imagine for example i
don't think he's a covert russian agent
and i don't think he is a rabid
determined racist
who is using appeals to white
nationalists to try
and sustain his power and i don't
believe that racial grievance is what
motivates the coalition that put him in
office but
again these are these are somewhat
heterodox perspectives but i think they
can be substantiated
but to the specific question of you know
biden versus trump and what the value
proposition is i'm reminded of a
conversation i had with yasha monk who
is the
founder of a new publication persuasion
and contributed to the atlantic and
other
august publications before that um but
we were talking specifically about you
know cancel culture
a phrase that i'm i don't love i don't
think it's
it catches enough it has too much of a
mean girl's feel to it it's easily
caricatured but
the the notion that the left is sort of
the force
that is animating that or at least
that's created a circumstance where
people like yasha
feel the need to leave where they are
and start something new
essentially generally formalize this new
center that seems to be emerging
um and yasha took great pains to express
a specific concern about the threat from
the populist right
and it just seemed a bit at odds to me
to note that
we're concerned about this wave
of of um
sort of censorship and speech policing
from the left
because they've managed to it seems
capture a lot of the elite institutions
and to change the atmosphere in a lot of
media organizations
but then we still take great pains to
talk about what is happening
on the right and you know i get that
donald trump is the president of the
united states
but in a future where the left owns
both the culture and the presidency
that actually seems like something that
might
give one pause and i don't have a great
answer to that
i don't know um what it is i will say
that donald trump
of all of his qualities the worst
quality is probably the degree to which
he seems to be able to break people's
brains
and the degree to which the scrambling
of norms
like i'd i'd hoped that having someone
who was
as sort of palpably awful and kind of
grotesque as donald trump
in the white house might turn people off
to like executive power and make them
say you know what
we can't trust governor that was a
wonderful 15 minutes when
yeah he was being sworn in and you saw
in the new york times and elsewhere like
hey maybe we were
went too far in glorifying executive
power and privilege under obama
yeah because now it's in the the grubby
hands of this
uh you know reality tv show
star um so that is a real concern one of
one of your answers and to kind of move
into uh
concluding i would love to talk with you
through the election
continuously so that i don't have to pay
attention to it but
alas something the memory of real life
uh intervenes but one of one of your
answers
um both with the fifth column as well as
uh with your the organization you form
with dan hayes former reason tv
videographer uh uh uh free think media
one of the things you did uh you know
when you say like you worry about the
left or anybody owning both political
power and cultural power is that you
created platforms to speak
can you talk a little bit about free
think media what it is
and where you're at with it now and why
why it's important and then i want to uh
you know probably shoot the [ __ ] a
little bit about the fifth column
yeah well free think and we just go by
free think now
is a media brand that is about
the things that are likely to matter a
hundred years from now a century
um several centuries from now the
remarkable innovations and ideas that
are likely to change the world for the
better
and we still believe that this is a
remarkable incredible time to be alive
and that there's all sorts of amazing
opportunities
and amazing people trying to achieve
great things
and we want to highlight that and
celebrate innovation and talk about how
we fix big problems
i think there is a tendency to to see
innovative new approaches and especially
amongst the mainstream media it's
regarded as serious if you are critical
and perhaps even a little bit cynical of
these new things
um but i think what are what are some of
what are some of the innovation specific
uh you know that you talked about in
your website as well as in the videos
which i think are
for me or what are most memorable about
yeah well we
yeah we specialize in video and i
appreciate that um ai
i think is a great example um i think in
popular culture
you know we're all familiar with the
terminator and various other dystopian
films about how miserable this
innovation is going to be
um or how potentially dangerous it is
but
i think there's a phenomenal and super
compelling story to be told about all of
the promise and possibility associated
with ai
the possibilities for medical
breakthroughs
for breakthroughs in computing
technology and the many many people who
are doing their best to mitigate what
many people imagine to be the risks of
ai
and that's a productive way to look at
that even the the sort of problematic
side
of this incredible new technology that
is coming
whether we like it or not yeah yeah well
that i mean is uh
you know is it might be the ultimate uh
point really is that this stuff happens
whether we like it or not whether we
sniff at it or or embrace it um why do
you think people
are so afraid of the future particularly
technological innovations and
and does that fear you know is it
related to uh
what you're talking about in the culture
of people wanting to
kind of strangle um you know different
opinions
and and anything that specs of
heterodoxy rather than some kind of new
orthodoxy
yeah that's a that's a hard question
i i suspect there are lots of reasons i
mean i i certainly think that with
respect to
computers and artificial intelligence
one of the chief concerns there is jobs
and you know the possibility that change
is going to disrupt
um the the situation that we're
comfortable with
in ways that we cannot control and do
not understand and i think that
uncertainty alone is perhaps enough
to put a rather pessimistic negative
gloss
on anything so this is the idea that oh
my god
self-driving cars it means i'm not going
to be a truck driver
or my children not i mean you know
when you were saying that i was starting
to think like maybe the reason why i
tend to be and maybe maybe overly
optimistic or uncritical
interested in new innovation and whatnot
is because
god i mean my up through my grandparents
all of my
on the gillespie side my father's side
the guida side
irish and italian these people for
thousands of years were yoked to the
land because they were peasant farmers
and fishermen
and it was only you know mechanized in
dust
industry and stuff like that that let
them leave you know [ __ ] farms behind
and that and the the kind of glamour of
that
shift which was totally because of
mechanization and industrialization
hasn't worn off yet yeah
um what um what about the fifth column
what do you
what is success uh you guys have a
wonderful podcast you have a
uh thank you you know if you were a band
it would be
uh you know you have fans that are like
fans of the velvet underground or maybe
the grateful dead because you're getting
bigger i mean people who just follow you
everywhere even on to patreon a gated
community
that kicks people off for things that
they do and say that have nothing to do
with patreon but you're willing
certainly
we're certainly aware
what would success uh what is success
for
the fifth column well i mean i think it
is uh
it's quite an achievement that folks
actually like listening to
you know the three of us and our array
of
guests and i don't think you've been one
yet i have nothing to do well that's
well you know i keep hearing that but my
invitation i feel like i'm not
here likes uh cinderella you know i'm
too busy cleaning the uh cleaning the
house
um but uh you know i think the fact that
we've attracted an audience at all
is something i'm enormously proud of and
honored
by um i think what we attempt to do is
both
um you know exercise our our own demons
have a little bit of fun in the process
and take
a take sharp aim at the
media and the news cycle and try to
help people understand you know how the
sausage gets made
why it gets made in a particular way and
bring people in who can help us uh
contextualize stories or explore the
perspective that they were recently
talking about
and do it in a way that is um
honest in some cases forceful
but welcoming and i think like genuinely
model
uh what good discourse look like looks
like and that doesn't mean that we don't
have sharp criticisms
and rebukes for people because we do and
i think that that's totally fair
um but it does mean that you know if
you're willing to come and have a
conversation with us like we'll have a
beer with you
and or or a gin and tonic or something
else even what about
a non-alcoholic beverage i'm not sure
you can have it
you can have an idea that's fine but
you'll make fun of me for having an
audience
no well yes no one is no one and nothing
is
safe so you will you will be made fun of
but we also make fun of each other but
i think that there's something something
really great
about being able to cultivate a platform
like that where people can know
they're going to get you know honest um
unvarnished opinions
where we'll you know take take some
risks occasionally
in terms of being honest and forthright
especially in a climate that is become
accustomed to punishing people for
straying from
uh is it a right to use the word
reservation i think it is i'm using it
anyway strain from the reservation
um and you know adopting perspectives
that are a bit more heterodox or even
just
asking questions that are completely
legitimate
if generally regarded as out of bounds
so we want to have a healthy innovative
complicated and funny and spontaneous
environment and i think that's one of
the things to keep in mind about
like speech protections you know part of
what you try to do
with speech protections and speech codes
is make the whole world safe
and rip all of the spontaneity out of it
and
i don't know it just seems like such an
awful barren wasteland
i don't know why you would want to live
in a place like that
you need a little bit of jostling from
time to time
and you need people who are willing to
to traffic in
dangerous ideas and to articulate
radical perspectives which
may eventually win the day you know so
much about our current
society the things that we accept is
like received wisdom
um notions of equality that we used to
seemingly universally celebrate are
things that were
promoted by radicals and i don't want to
lose those people
because i don't think we've protect
perfected humanity or society yet
okay we're going to leave it there we
have been talking with camille foster he
is the co-founder of free think media
and the co-founder of the fifth column
podcast
he is the future chief of staff in the
second or third kanye west
administration
this has been the recent interview with
nick gillespie please subscribe
to this podcast at apple google stitcher
soundcloud spotify
wherever you get your podcast or go to
reason.com
podcasts and check out not just
the reason interview but the reason
roundtable in the soho forum debates
thanks so much for listening